[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est science public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportages et d'expertise sur publicella
en étant ensemble pour 90 minutes avec
deux grands thèmes comme tous les soirs
l'inflation profite à Marine Le pencer
la principale leçon du baromètre au doxa
du mois d'octobre la présidente du
rassemblement national qui a réussi un
coup politique hier soir en votant la
motion de censure de la Nupe on
analysera cet actualité évidemment mais
aussi les conséquences politiques d'une
rentrée sociale tourmentée dans une
minute et puis dans ce sens public c'est
une semaine spéciale défi énergétique
que je vous propose on parlera des
éoliennes demain des énergies du futur
jeudi et ce soir c'est la stratégie
nucléaire française que l'on va
décortiquer avec un virage historique
que certains regrettent aujourd'hui
celui promis par le candidat François
Hollande en 2011
je propose à l'horizon 2025 c'est à peu
près l'horizon comparable à celui des
Allemands nous ayons diminué de 75% un
peu plus de 50% la part du nucléaire une
décennie plus tard Emmanuel Macron
relance le nucléaire en construisant 6
nouveaux réacteurs est-ce déjà trop tard
comment rattraper le manque
d'investissement de ces dernières années
est-ce forcément le bon choix en
débattra dans 45 minutes mais d'abord
donc cette surprise signée Le Pen hier
les députés RN qui votent avec ceux de
la nup une vraie fausse alliance des
extrêmes que nous raconte Jérôme Rabier
tout semblait écrit d'avance hier à
l'Assemblée la nuque et le RN devait
chacun voter pour leur motion de censure
les LR s'abstenir et le gouvernement
sauvé tranquillement sa peau mais
c'était sans compter sur Marine Le Pen
qui a la tribune à bousculé le plan
établi et
[Applaudissements]
parce
que votre a également la motion de
censure présentée en des termes
acceptables de l'autre côté de
l'hémicycle une décision qui a
déstabilisé les autres groupes
politiques les LR peuvent ainsi
apparaître comme les alliés du
gouvernement puisqu’esser leur absence
de vote qui permet au gouvernement de se
maintenir certains élus la nu-pétaient
aussi gênés de voter le même texte que
le rassemblement national et le
gouvernement est désormais prévenu il
peut être renversé si les LR se joignent
au mouvement cela prouve que le
rassemblement national a développé une
stratégie très très habile en matière de
joute parlementaire
on ne s'y attendait pas d'ailleurs mais
c'est vrai que c'est un coup tacticien
assez formidable ça le positionne quand
même à la fois en force d'opposition
donc ça confirme bien que c'est une
force de position mais en même temps
constructive ce qui aussi lui permet de
prendre ses distances avec la nuque un
rôle de premier opposant que le RN ne
compte pas laisser et qui s'inscrit
aussi dans une stratégie plus large de
respectabilité c'est de montrer que et
bien certes il y a la crédibilité mais
cette crédibilité c'est une crédibilité
d'alternative au gouvernement dans le
cas d'une alternance et que donc ce
faisant tout ce qui sera bon pour faire
ton base gouvernement le RN y est prêt
et que donc pour ceux qui voudraient
être tenté de se débarrasser de la
précédente majorité et bien il ne faut
pas se tourner vers LR qui ne vote pas
l'émotion censure mais plutôt vers le RN
qu'il évoque une stratégie qui semble
payer selon notre enquête odoxam mascara
Marine Le Pen voit sa cote d'adhésion
progresser de deux points ce mois-ci
atteignant 34%, elle est ainsi la
deuxième personnalité du baromètre dans
ce domaine derrière Édouard Philippe
je vous présente tout de suite les
invités de ce premier débat dans
Sciences publicitaire Charlène bézine à
bonsoir vous êtes
constitutionnaliste maître de conférence
en droit public Gael Slimane président
co-fondateur de doxam bonsoir Gaëlle
Jean-Marie Pernaut bonsoir bienvenue à
vous vous êtes chercheur associés à
l'Institut de recherche économique et
social auteur de ce livre le
syndicalisme d'après publié aux éditions
du retour on a également avec nous en
duplex en visioconférence Yves sensi qui
est seniors partner chez mascaret
mascara évidemment qui travaille sur ce
baromètre avec odoxa pour Public Sénat
LCP et la presse quotidienne régionale
vous scrutez les réseaux sociaux pour
pour nous et puis j'accueille aussi
Laetitia que ça éditoris politique
bonsoir les Laetitia allez on réagit à
ce à ce bon coup politique c'est un peu
ce que tout le monde dit depuis ce matin
Charlène bézina et vous
de la part de Marine Le Pen évidemment
alors en effet la Cinquième République
est ainsi faite que les oppositions ne
sont pas grand-chose tant qu'elles ne se
coalise pas donc on aurait l'impression
avec l'acte d'hier qu'un premier front
d'opposition a existé puisqu'il faut se
rappeler quand même que sur la question
de confiance l'article 49-1 cette
fois-ci et bien les deux oppositions
n'avaient pas voulu être en coordination
donc c'est vrai que c'est la première
fois sous ce quinquennat et c'est
relativement sous cette législature et
son secret canard que on a une
opposition coalisée c'est relativement
tôt donc ça peut voilà ça peut nous dire
que les oppositions ne sont pas si
éloignées que ça contrairement à ce que
l'on croit néanmoins moi il y a quelque
chose qui me fait dire que le coup
politique est à la un peu à double
tranchant parce que il a été la le
synonyme d'une vraie volte-face
puisqu'on a au départ un RN qui nous dit
qu'il va voter sa propre émotion de
censure de son côté et qui change d'avis
dans l'hémicycle c'est-à-dire on ne sait
même pas si la réunion de groupe
auparavant avait permis d'acter
d'entériner le changement de vote donc
c'est de mémoire la première fois sous
la Cinquième République on a un groupe
qui change aussi à la dernière minute et
aussi radicalement de positionnement je
ne suis pas sûr que ça favorise
complètement la lisibilité de ce groupe
parlementaire par rapport à son
positionnement d'opposition il faudra
quand même choisir alors effectivement
si on analyse je rappelle que le
baromètre évidemment vous ne l'avez
réalisé avant ce coup politique de
Marine Le Pen donc on regarde son dans
le son il était dit et d'ailleurs mais
il est probable moi je pense qu'elle
gagnerait encore des points alors après
ce coup ça sera intéressant à suivre
dans les dans les prochains jours
effectivement mais de votre connaissance
de votre expertise de de l'opinion
est-ce que ce vote commun avec la nuque
peut perturber ou pas une partie de son
électorat à Marine Le Pen non je ne
crois pas je pense je souscris tout à
fait à ce qui est Diane Charlotte à
l'instant sur le côté surprenant à la
fois inédit et surprenant de de se
raviser et finalement de prendre cette
décision et d'être soi-même surpris et
d'avoir probablement surpris un petit
peu ces mi-temps parce que ils avaient
dit du côté du rassemblement national
elle avait dit Marine Le Pen très
clairement qu'elle n'aurait aucun
problème à voter avec la nupes sur un
certain nombre de texte et notamment sur
la réforme des retraites s'il y avait
une réforme des retraites avec 49 profs
elle avait émis tout un tas d'hypothèses
où elle disait je dans ce cas là je
n'aurai aucun problème à voter avec la
nupette mais pas cette fois
pour autant je pense que c'est une bonne
stratégie ou une bonne tactique qu'elle
a qu'elle a choisi là parce que comme ça
a été dit dans le sujet ça la positionne
à la fois comme
une candidate capable de faire d'être en
mesure de faire tomber le gouvernement
ou de mettre en place les ingrédients
qu'il faut pour cela et en même temps
comme une candidate et un parti
respectable ça contribue tout ça c'est
une pierre de plus dans les défis
général de la respectabilité qu'elle a
réussi à se construire et puis on en a
beaucoup parlé dans cette émission
lorsqu'on suivait la présidentielle elle
a été beaucoup aidée elle a été beaucoup
aidée par les Outrans parfois de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur la gauche et puis
par la posture d'Éric Zemmour qui a un
moment donné ça on l'a bien enregistré
dans les enquêtes a pu faire passer
Marine Le Pen pour finalement du pour
reprendre une vieille expression du Le
Pen très lights grâce à Zemmour donc je
pense que c'est une bonne stratégie et
je pense que si on sondait aujourd'hui
les Français ce n'est peut-être pas un
point ou deux qu'elle gagnerait et en
plus par rapport à d'autres rivaux qui
perdent des points mais c'est sans doute
davantage après ce que ça durera c'est
pas sûr
Jean-Marie Pernaut derrière cette ce
coup politique il y a toujours la
question de qui parle aux classes
populaires dans ce bras de fer entre le
rassemblement national et la nuque mais
j'aurais plutôt vous entendre sur sur la
nu parce qu'elle est-ce qu'elle peut
parce que j'entendais ce matin
Clémentine au teint par exemple sur RTL
dire on peut incarner l'espoir
l'espérance c'est nous est-ce que la nu
pour vous peut incarner cette
alternative crédible ou cette expérience
à gauche aujourd'hui il faudrait
reprendre un peu la trajectoire de la
gauche depuis une trentaine d'années en
France et ailleurs parce que c'est pas
qu'un problème français le problème
d'identifier les parties socialistes en
Europe c'est un c'est un vrai sujet avec
des différences ou à l'Espagne Portugal
d'un côté le l'Allemagne le Royaume-Uni
voir les Nordiques de l'autre donc sans
parler des pays d'Europe centrale qui
posent un autre problème mais
bon je crois il y a une grave crise de
d'identité de la gauche aujourd'hui en
Europe c'est très clair et je pense que
tous les socialistes qui ont été
embarqués dans les années 80-90 dans le
tournant Léo libéral ont vu le retour de
flammes assez violent notamment de la
part des classes populaires puisque ils
incarnaient un peu les espérances de ces
groupes sociaux-là or les preuves du
pouvoir pendant 20 à 30 ans pour
certains les a vu s'aligner quand même
globalement sur une sorte un certain
type d'orthodoxie
néolibéral et du coup je pense que
aujourd'hui ils vont avoir du mal à
reconstruire une espérance de leur côté
je pense que c'est là dessus aussi que
que surf Marine Le Pen c'est que
l'attente des classes populaires
beaucoup de gens pour justifier le vote
Front national cela on les a pas essayés
voilà c'est bah oui les autres on a vu
on a vu comment ça a fini le désastre
électoral du quinquennat Hollande etc ça
se refait pas en deux ans je pense que
on
il faut du temps pour moi la nupesse
n'est qu'un moment de cette
reconstruction elle est fragile par
construction elle est pas elle a des
problèmes de leadership bon voilà et je
pense qu'il faudra du temps pour que la
gauche redevienne crédible aux yeux des
gens qui ont des attentes sociales assez
fortes donc le RN a voté la motion de
censure de la nuque mais l'inverse n'est
pas vrai et Clémentine Autain justement
le justifier ce matin c'est aussi parce
que nous avons écouté ce qu'a dit Marine
Le Pen nous avons lu aussi ce qui a mis
dans sa motion parce que dans les
commentaires j'ai lu mais je suis tombée
de ma chaise j'ai lu à la motion de
censure et très consensuelle celle de
l'extrême droite il y est question de
crise minière grattoir et sécuritaire
trouver ça très consensuel moi j'estime
c'est un point de vue politique elle dit
l'urgence l'alternance elle a dit plein
d'autres choses hier absolument
épouvantable sur le fond politique qui
est un vraiment
ramassis de propos qui sont des propos
de nature à engendrer la guerre civile
dans notre pays voilà le projet de
l'extrême droite je l'ai bien écouté
hier Marine Le Pen donc l'idée que on
ferait par une astuce en disant les
extrêmes vous voyez ce qu'a dit elle
disait de bornière c'est l'alliance des
extrêmes une alliance contre nature il
n'y a pas d'alliance des extrêmes il n'y
aura pas de projets communs en revanche
il y a une majorité dans le pays pour ne
pas être d'accord avec ce que fait le
gouvernement
je pense que c'est là la force de Marine
Le Pen c'est qu'elle l'illustre et elle
incarne la jonction des pôles la langue
des extrêmes ceci de la jonction des
pôles c'est une théorie qui a été mis
sur la table par différents politologues
depuis longtemps qui a été illustré
aussi par toutes les vagues de populisme
qu'on a vu dans les autres pays la
France a été presque atteinte mais pas
encore et donc on voit bien que les
électorats sont prêts eux à se rejoindre
peut-être pas encore Clémentine Notin et
des figures politiques voyez-vous mais
comme Marine Le Pen a fait cette lecture
là et c'est que des électorats des
extrêmes peuvent se rejoindre pour
renverser les élites et le système parce
que c'est un peu tout ça le langage elle
sait que ça peut fonctionner et que ça
sera efficace mais alors justement sur
les électorats challengeina c'est
finalement la seconde entend dans le la
réaction Clémentine notarde ce qui ce
qu'on peut trouver de commun au RN et à
la Nupe c'est la volonté de bloquer ou
dans ou de freiner le gouvernement mais
est-ce que c'est le mandat que leurs
électeurs leur ont donné au législatives
c'est paradoxal parce qu'en réalité on
attend de l'opposition qu'elle s'oppose
donc nécessairement qu'elle soit dans le
contre avec la majorité et à ce
moment-là on peut estimer que des
oppositions qui s'allient voilà c'est
tout à fait leur mandat que de renverser
la politique en place néanmoins on n'a
pas en France un système aussi clair que
le système britannique ou le système
allemand ou lorsque vous démettez il
faut absolument que vous soyez en
capacité de proposer quelque chose
d'alternative donc vous ne pouvez pas
par exemple en Allemagne d'émettre un
premier ministre tant que vous n'avez
pas une proposition alternative d'un
autre Premier ministre avec un programme
en plus alors moi je rejoins ce que ce
que vous avez dit parce que je pense
nécessairement que les populistes ou la
manière de parler au peuple est
exactement la même comprennent un
extrait ou un autre et comme vous l'avez
dit il y a beaucoup d'expérience de
droits comparés notamment dans
l'Amérique du Sud qui prouve bien qu'on
peut avoir populisme de gauche
contrairement à ce qu'on entend très
souvent et je crois que
la manière dont ces oppositions parfois
sont au pied à pied sur certains acquis
sociaux je pense notamment au vote de la
LSS ou au vote du budget de cette année
et bien contrairement à ce qu'ils
adorent marteler je crois qu'ils sont
quand même très proches politiquesment
sur leurs projets de déconstruction de
certains acquis du libéralisme etc donc
il y a il y a évidemment des points de
communauté même si politiquement c'est
toujours tendancieux de se mettre
d'accord alors qu'on est aussi opposé
sur le point de vue des couleurs
politiques et des mouvements surtout de
racines que sont les racines historiques
de ces deux mouvements Jean-Marc Pernaut
faisiez si vous voulez intervenir oui
non parce que je suis assez troublé de
de cette espèce de on parle de
l'alliance des extrêmes mais je voudrais
qu'on m'explique en quoi le programme de
la nupesse est un programme extrême
alors je parle pas je relisais il y a
pas très longtemps pour des besoins
universitaires le programme commun de
gouvernement du 1980 pour ne pas parler
du programme changer la vie du parti
socialiste de 19 1972 mais là vous avez
des programmes extrêmes le programme de
la nups je suis désolé c'est le
programme en gros de Pedro Sanchez que
qu'il met en oeuvre en Espagne c'est en
gros le programme que met en oeuvre le
Premier ministre portugais je vois pas
très bien ce qu'il y a d'extrême
là-dedans par ailleurs l'idée de
gouverner ensemble enfin il y a quand
même des points durs on a entendu
Clémentine Autain sur la question du
rapport aux étrangers sur la question de
la fiscalité enfin le programme du RN
c'est quoi c'est poursuivre le
déshabillage fiscal notamment l'impôt
sur le revenu comment vous pouvez
imaginer que il puisse y avoir le
moindre programme commun entre ces deux
orientations politiques là après il y a
la tambouille parlementaire c'est
évident que lorsque les gens veulent se
caler sur je suis le plus grand opposant
à Macron au gouvernement en place au
groupe parlementaire dominant bon
évidemment il va y avoir des
conjonctions tactiques un moment donné
là c'est un coût tactique assez bien
joué de la part du RN qu'est-ce que ça
anticipe sur la capacité à gouverner en
commun moi je pense que la capacité à
gouverner en commun elle est regardée
l'Italie c'est là qu'elle est et le pari
de Marine Le Pen c'est pas de gouverner
avec la nups
qui pourrait passer au RN c'est
l'électoral c'est des médicaments
vous avez raison mais elle se fait sur
des questions sur des questions de fond
mais l'idée que ça puisse présager d'une
alliance par le mentale je crois qu'il y
a très loin entre ça et la tactique
politicienne je suis tel bien vu bien
sûr je précise mon propos en une petite
seconde je n'ai absolument pas envisagé
je ne pense pas qu'il soit envisageable
ni sous cette législature ni sous une
prochaine qu'un accord de gouvernement
soit trouvé entre les deux extrêmes et
encore une fois quand je parle des
extrêmes je ne parle évidemment pas de
la nuance de la nupes mais plutôt de
clémentine Notin qui qui parlait au nom
du groupe LFI ici et encore une fois je
martèle par contre que je vois des
communautés de discours politiques entre
ce que j'appelle justement les
populistes de gauche et les populismes
de droite dans les extrémités notamment
parce que vous avez la sortie d'Union
européenne vous avez un discours très
critique par rapport à l'état droit au
juge au Liberté et vous n'avez
évidemment aucun regroupement par
rapport à un programme de gouvernance
commun qui n'est ni souhaité par le
peuple ni souhaité par les autres mais
néanmoins cette communication fait que
les électorats sont très volatiles entre
l'un et l'autre et je pense précisément
que le jeu politique de Marine Le Pen en
prouvant que les oppositions peuvent
s'allier pour démettre la majorité en
place travail sur ce fil là c'est à dire
sur l'idée que une autre gouvernance est
possible mais ensuite je vous rejoins
totalement je pense que les deux
programmes sont différents mais les
électorats sont très poreux par rapport
à un certain discours politique que je
crois être vraiment commun alors on va
détailler les résultats du baromètre au
doxam mascara mais je voudrais d'abord
me tourner vers vous et ils sont aussi
pour faire un tour sur le les réactions
sur les médias sociaux pas à pas de de
ce coup politique de Marine Le Pen mais
plus généralement là on parle d'un
parlement qui est plus on va dire
éruptif que constructif est-ce que tous
les toutes les personnalités politiques
sont raillées sont moqués tel que vous
le le percevez dans votre vie des
réseaux sociaux oui en effet c'est un
peu ce qu'on avait observé en complément
du commentaire de
doxa c'est-à-dire que sur les réseaux
sociaux le sait ce sont des alors c'est
pas un lieu à part les réseaux sociaux
ça reste un forum de citoyens mais sur
lequel
l'expression sera avant tout une
expression émotionnelle une expression
de sentiments et ce qu'on a noté en tout
cas dans le dans le dernier mois
c'est une période particulièrement
difficile pour l'ensemble des on va dire
du personnel politique qui s'agisse du
gouvernement ou qu'il s'agisse des
oppositions c'est à dire qu'en gros
on a sur les sujets qui sont les sujets
difficiles pour les Français c'est à
dire que depuis que
cet été la question du climat est devenu
une question énergétique mais touchant
le portefeuille des Français on voit
monter sur les réseaux sociaux une
colère qu'on peut qualifier de très très
forte et à partir du moment où on a
cette colère qui monte et qu'on constate
par ailleurs
une certaine
inadéquation entre les discours
politiques et les réponses qu'attendent
les citoyens au travers des réseaux
sociaux
la réaction c'est ce qu'on a appelé la
raillerie la raillerie la moquerie
accusant un petit peu que ce soit le
gouvernement ou les oppositions d'être à
côté de la plaque sur sur un certain
nombre de sujets ce qu'on voit en
conséquence ce mois-ci c'est une montée
de ce qu'on appelle les intervenants
anti-systèmes évidemment intéressant
d'avoir cet éclairage merci Yves
saint-cy on va donc détailler les
résultats de ce baromètre baromètre
odoxa mascara pour Public Sénat LCP
et la presse quotidienne régionale je
propose à Quentin calmer de nous
rejoindre on va démarrer avec la hausse
des prix le point de départ Quentin qui
nous faisait pris qu'un pacte tous les
Français oui c'est ça le chiffre MS
massif 96 % des Français interrogés on
le sentiment que leur pouvoir d'achat
est déjà impacté par la hausse des prix
selon effectivement ce baromètre sm56
des Français qui disent être très
affectés une inflation qui a un fort
impact sur les comportements de
consommation il tombe dans l'étude sont
toujours en matière d'énergie mais c'est
sans doute liée aux pénuries dans les
stations de service mais on voit
l'évolution sur tous les thèmes testés
vêtements consommation quotidienne
produit alimentaire vacance et loisirs
autour de 80% des Français interrogés
disent avoir modifié leur comportement
où vont le faire et on voit des
évolutions fortes depuis juin 2022
jusqu'à 10 points sur les produits
alimentaires Thomas et alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est aussi la perception de
l'action du gouvernement face à cette
inflation voilà le sentiment général est
majoritairement négatif 36% des
personnes interrogées estiment que le
gouvernement n'agit pas ou
insuffisamment 37% estiment qu'il
pourrait en faire plus seul 26% estiment
que le gouvernement agit beaucoup
agit déjà beaucoup conséquences
Elisabeth borne perd 6 points popularité
entre fin septembre et fin octobre avec
35 % d'opinion positives contre 63% des
Français qui ont une opinion défavorable
d'Elizabeth borne et il va être borne
qui sert un peu de paratonnerre au
président de la République qui lui ne
perd que trois points de popularité et
ce contexte social sert-il à gauche et
bien non c'est le paradoxe que notre les
sondeurs l'adhésion à Marine Le Pen
progresse
à un mois en un mois de deux points soit
12 de 12 points de plus que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon elle est à la deuxième place
du classement comme le disait aussi
Jérôme rabais dans son reportage et donc
le classement des personnes qui
suscitent le rejet Jean-Luc Mélenchon
est au-dessus de Marine Le Pen ils sont
respectivement à 54 et 45% des personnes
interrogées merci beaucoup Quentin
Gaëlle Slimane on encore un peu plus
détaillé ce baromètre on viendra sur les
les codes de d'adhésion hydrogés qui
sont toujours vraiment intéressantes à
analyser il y a d'abord le décrochage de
l'exécutif c'est est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec l'analyse de Quentin quand
il dit que j'ai envie de partir parce
que je peux plus rien à faire ici
un peu de paratonnerre vrai ou faux oui
oui vrai on a alors c'est le le lot des
sondages vous savez je nous revoie
encore le mois dernier disant oh en
cette rentrée c'est incroyable la
première ministre progresse nettement
elle est partie de bas pour un premier
ministre et puis finalement elle a pris
et se faire connaître ce qui est vrai
pendant cet été elle avait elle avait
marqué des points dans l'opinion mais là
c'est c'est ce que je reviens je rejoins
ce que disait ifs sensibles mascarez ce
qu'il a noté sur les réseaux sociaux ce
qu'on enregistre dans nos études les
gens n'ont marre vous avez sur les
pénuries de carburant on avait fait
d'autres sondages qui montrait que les
trois quarts de la population était
touchées là sur l'inflation les chiffres
ont été rappelés si on ne prend que ceux
qui disaient très affecté c'est plus
d'une personne sur deux dans ces
comportements de consommation du
quotidien donc par rapport à ça il y a
une attente
s'agissant des réquisitions des
personnels des raffineries les Français
dans les enquêtes que nous avions
réalisé les autres enquêtes nous
disaient qu'ils les attendaient plus
vite plus tôt plus fort
ils ont le sentiment que le contenu est
pas donc il est assez logique que la
première ministre qui est en première
ligne sur ces sujets là soit affectés le
président est aussi parce que les
baisses et les baisses ne sont pas les
mêmes pour l'un et l'autre mais les
codes de popularité elles sont assez
comparables on est sous les 40% de
popularité et on rejoint ce climat un
peu triste c'est-à-dire que vous avez un
exécutif qui qui est perçu comme pas
très efficace mais vous n'avez pas de
relais ni à gauche ni vraiment ailleurs
et puis peut-être moi j'ai ressenti un
décalage alors au-delà de la crise des
raffineries sur les les mesures de de
bon sens le plan de communication du
gouvernement sur faites des économies
etc etc cette idée que les Français ils
les avaient déjà faites ils économies
depuis pour les trois quarts d'entre eux
depuis longtemps donc vous voyez ce
décalage plus la colle rouler ou la
doudoune ou c'est ce type de sujet je
crois que Yves ne me contredira pas sur
les réseaux sociaux ça se voit beaucoup
parce qu'il y a du il y a du verbe
intime et donc il y a beaucoup de
moqueries beaucoup parce que les
Français nous disent mais enfin ça fait
un moment que pour des raisons
environnementales et puis aussi des
raisons de source de difficultés
évidemment que j'ai baissé ma
température autant que je pouvais
évidemment que je prends le moins
possible voilà je fais mes machines la
nuit je vais prendre ma voiture le moins
souvent possible parce que tout ça ça me
coûte de l'argent et puis parce que il y
a aussi une préoccupation
environnementale donc les conseils
donnés de ce point de vue là paraissent
un peu à côté de la plaque mais quand
même Jean-Marie Pernaut il faut il faut
rappeler que notre pays est l'un de ceux
ou l'inflation est la plus faible en
Europe parce qu'il y a des détails qui
sont importantes mais là tels qui sont
sondées par par notre baromètre le
français finalement
ne sont pas n'en tiennent pas une aspect
positif je n’arrive pas à trouver mes
mots pour le gouvernement
en font en rigueur ils n'en font pas
crédible dans l'item testé dans la
question c'est les deux un peu mon
capitaine quand même parce que on nous
dit on a proposé le gouvernement à JD
beaucoup les Français sont bien plus
protégés que nous ne le sont leurs
voisins européens des effets de
l'inflation ce qui est objectivement
vrai et ça on a seulement 26% des gens
qui adhèrent à cette idée là les autres
c'est pas qu'ils disent que c'est faux
c'est qu'ils disent ok on fait déjà des
choses mais on en attend davantage parce
que nous sommes en France et parce que
dans notre système il y a des
amortisseurs sociaux on n'est pas on
n'est pas des Anglais voilà quand vous
l'expliquer ça est-ce qu'il y a une
forme de de d'injustice ou d'un
gratitude je ne sais pas d'abord il est
assez rare que les gens fassent un
benchmark international comme on dit
pour se faire une opinion
donc ça je crois que c'est la première
chose la deuxième qu'il faudrait avoir
en tête c'est que
l'indice l'Insee c'est pas un indice de
coût de la vie c'est un indice
économique enfin l'Insee le répète quand
on lui demande c'est pas un indice du
coût de la vie ça prend tous les prix
c'est pas c'est pas le panier du ménager
ou de l'aménageur je pense que le
ressenti aujourd'hui des Français que
vous avez rappelé il est lié à ça c'est
qu'en fait ce qu'ils vivent comme hausse
des prix c'est nettement supérieur au
taux d'inflation parce que le reste à
vivre c'est à menuiser très sérieusement
alors après vous allez leur dire oui
mais c'est nettement mieux qu'en Italie
ou ou en Espagne ou autre qui d'ailleurs
dans certains cas reste un petit peu à
voir mais bon a mis de l'argent dans
l'affaire c'est clair mais mais bon ok
il a mis de l'argent dans l'affaire sauf
que nous on a déjà effectivement opérer
les restrictions qui convenaient chacun
a conscience que c'est pas fini parce
que il y a aussi quand même cette guerre
en Ukraine qui qui s'enquiste dans le
paysage et dont on sait très bien
qu'elle a des conséquences économiques
qu'elle en aura au-delà même des
problèmes de pétrole de grève de
raffinerie etc on a là un enjeu qui est
quand même beaucoup plus sévère et que
les gens perçoivent parce que la guerre
en Ukraine elle est de l'ouverture de
tous les journaux télévisés radio à
juste titre et que c'est quelque chose
qui va impacter leur vie et que ça
progressivement ils en prennent
conscience
il y a eu quand même dans ce contexte de
grève des raffineries il y a eu ce
mouvement qui était annoncé depuis
longtemps cette journée de mobilisation
lancée par la nuque contre la vie chère
et pourtant on voit pas forcément
la nuque ou la nupesse en profiter alors
que Marine Le Pen profite de cette
situation en tout cas un peu plus
comment vous l'analyse
que je tire de ce baromètre et la grande
inquiétude de la constitutionnaliste que
je suis c'est que finalement on voit
bien que le politique la politique mais
même dans son sens le plus noble l'art
de la cité ne séduit plus les Français
et non seulement ne les séduit plus mais
ne les convaincu par rapport à à
l'efficacité de ce discours politique en
fait on voit bien que la majorité ne
profite pas évidemment on a envie de
dire de de ces moments mais l'opposition
non plus donc on n'a pas de vecteur de
canalisation puisque les mouvements
sociaux les syndicats apparemment non
plus pas véritablement cette colère donc
on se demande où elle va vraiment aller
et le risque et on va on va revenir sur
les populismes ici le risque est ici de
revenir un ras-le-bol et un discours
politique justement du rejet mais en
plus que de la construction qui viendra
de la part des Français donc elle n'est
pas politique la question est est-ce
qu'elle va parler en tant que politique
ou est-ce qu'elle va parler un peu aux
affaires parce qu'on écoutait tout à
l'heure le barème réseaux sociaux et je
pense vraiment que le la force des
populismes il faut le dire c'est de
parler à la fête précisément donc je
pense que ce type de mouvement est
avantagé parce que on utilise les
ressorts de la colère les ressorts aussi
du sentimentalisme dans ces moments-là
et c'est souvent comme ça que ça
fonctionne sur justement les aides qui
sont à porter et l'éventuelle en
gratitude que que ces mouvements
pourraient traduire moi je crois aussi
que ces aides sont proprement
elles-mêmes porteuses d'angoisse
puisqu'on sait très bien qu'un quoi
qu'il en coûte est temporel déjà et
qu'en plus il signifie qu'on est en
train d'éponger une fuite permet dont on
n'a pas nécessairement la conscience de
la source et je crois que les Français
sont assez conscients qu'il y a des
causes endogènes on a parlé de la guerre
en Ukraine de la hausse des prix de
l'état de notre économie de l'État aussi
de nos politiques à l'international la
politique ne séduit plus nulle part il y
a vraiment pas qu'en France qui a
décrochage donc je crois que toutes ces
causes là créent l'angoisse et crée le
ras-le-bol aussi donc je pense pas que
les aides suffisent à cela un témoignage
justement lors de cette manifestation le
18 octobre dernier on est à Nantes alors
là c'est pas c'est pas le mouvement
contre la richesse c'est la grève
interprofessionnelle pour les salaires
lancés par les syndicats c'est un
hospitalier du CHU de Nantes qui
témoigne on est surtout en colère
c'est-à-dire que face à toute cette
perte de pouvoir d'achat en fait il y a
aucune aucune réponse de la part de ce
gouvernement juste à dire que en fait
les gens sont là que pour bloquer les la
vraie revendication des gens qui sont
dans la rue actuellement c'est le
pouvoir d'achat et l'augmentation
salariale
oui je voulais juste préciser que il y a
eu plusieurs mouvements et plusieurs
sujets de colère sociale de
mécontentement social il y en a eu un
très spectaculaire visible que les gens
ont vu ressenti qui a été la grève dans
les raffineries ça a été le point de
départ et puis vous avez d'autres
mouvements on a vu ce syndical cela et
on se trouve qu'on dans d'autres
sondages on a pu tester l'image des
mouvements le problème c'est que le
mouvement le plus visible était de très
loin le plus impopulaire celui dans les
raffineries le perçu comme étant c'est
pas moi qui juge mais dans l'opinion le
moins légitime
et puis il y a des mouvements qui
parlaient davantage aux Français les
mouvements on a vu ce syndicaliste là
par exemple de ce type l'idée d'une
marche contre la vie chère ça peut
séduire donc la difficulté pour la nupes
et ses figures de pouvoir coaguler des
mécontentement c'est qu'il y a des
sujets où le gréviste et le sujet
lui-même du mécontentement dans les
raffineries et puis d'autres sujets où
on se dit il fait grave par procuration
pour moi il a raison et donc c'est cette
moyennisation des deux qui fait que
personne ne tire les marrons du feu de
cette situation à part un petit peu
Marine Le Pen parce que Marine Le Pen
elle engrange quand elle ne dit rien et
sur les réseaux sociaux c'est pour ça
que c'est intéressant d'avoir les deux
sondages et réseaux sociaux il y a
quelque chose que je n'enregistre pas
encore dans mon sondage et que mascara
enregistre sur les réseaux sociaux c'est
que il y a un reproche qui est en train
de monter contre Marine Le Pen et qui
est monté contre Éric Zemmour sur la
tentation de récupération politique de
l'affaire de la petite Lola et donc là
on est sur quelque chose qui n'a rien à
voir avec ce dont on parlait
précédemment mais qui peut peut-être
l'affecter quand même et ça on
l'enregistre pas encore dans le sondage
mais c'est possible que ça joue plus
tard je vais rester sur la la crise
sociale Jean-Marie Pernaut parce que
c'est clairement un enjeu majeur de ces
prochains mois la façon dont cette crise
du pouvoir d'achat se transforme ou non
en mouvement social profond alors c'est
certainement difficile à anticiper et la
question subsidiaire c'est est-ce que
les syndicats peuvent être à l'origine
est-ce qu'ils ont encore le le poids la
capacité à être à l'origine d'un
mouvement social profond la crise
sociale elle bon sur les salaires c'est
un petit peu là comment elle va
s'exprimer quelle forme elle va prendre
il y a déjà pas mal de conflits sur les
salaires quand même depuis quelques
temps celui des raffineries
effectivement à beaucoup mobilisé
l'attention mais du coup faire un petit
peu disparaître les autres conflits très
nombreux qui a dans les entreprises bon
c'est assez classique dans ce genre de
dans ce genre de contexte ou les
syndicats doivent reprendre un peu la
culture de l'inflation qui sont perdus
aussi la question du salaire on
l'évoquait il y a pas très longtemps
redevient un peu au cœur de et là il y a
quand même une un bras de fer qui peut
qui peut
se mettre en place autour de la question
du salaire c'est que pour l'instant ce
que fait le gouvernement il bouche les
trous que vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
il y a des fuites on met des éponges on
met des sauts c'est à dire on met des
primes on met des bonus on met des
tickets des boucliers de ceci bouclier
de cela mais il y a le compte il est pas
c'est-à-dire que le temps que la dérive
des prix si l'inflation est durée un an
ou deux il y a pas de problème on passe
un mauvais câble ça revient mais si on
décroche les salaires durablement on a
des problèmes derrière et ça les gens le
savent très bien la prime elle est
engloutie dans les 15 jours qui suivent
le mois d'après il faut quand même
recommencer avec le salaire d'avant donc
donc ça va pas donc il y a déjà cette
caisse comment va mûrir la question la
perception de la question salariale là
quand même les syndicats ont un discours
et ils l'ont tous c'est-à-dire que bon
le conflit total a aussi c'est ça c'est
problème cristalliser une opposition au
sein d'un mouvement syndical qui par
ailleurs commençait plutôt à se réunir
sur la question des retraites sur la
question de l'assurance chômage on avait
un rapprochement des organisations
syndicales et moi je crois que ainsi
nommé crise sociale quelle forme elle
prendra elle peut mûrir à partir du
moment où les syndicats auront porteront
une voie commune sur un certain nombre
de sujets et je pense à cet égard que la
question des retraites va être décisive
c'est-à-dire que dans le contexte actuel
alors vous avez évoqué le recul de de
Macron mais à mon avis ça ça le gène pas
trop je rappelle quand même qu'entre son
premier élection de 2017 et décembre
2018 un an après il avait perdu la
moitié de ses soutiens 27% d'opinion
favorable il sait faire avec ça et ça
n'empêche pas de gouverner alors et là
c'est plus haut ce que vous nous dites
dans votre sondage donc bon Macron ça le
gênera pas de après il y a peut-être sur
le social l'idée que ils arrivent à rien
les syndicats on a bien vu etc je pense
que ça serait assez imprudent de
continuer comme ça parce que les
retraites c'est quelque chose qui peut
cristalliser vous avez raison le conflit
des raffineries ne pouvait pas en
revanche sur les retraites on a déjà
donné pour voir il y a une douzaine
d'années là dessus ça peut être le
détonateur de quelque chose c'est
intéressant parce que il y a évidemment
une question dans cette réforme de la
retraite qui est l'attitude de LR le
soutien de LR je me tourne vers vous
Laetitia parce que vous vouliez faire un
focus dans dans ce débat sur
l'interview de Nicolas Sarkozy au
Journal du Dimanche pourquoi cette
interview fleuve au JDD qui lui a
accordé sa Une dimanche matin ça a
commencé comme ça pour moi Thomas
pourquoi pourquoi maintenant pourquoi
Nicolas Sarkozy a une du JD et puis tout
d'un coup je me suis rappelé qu'il était
quand même membre du conseil
d'administration du groupe Lagardère et
que il aimait bien aussi un peu mettre
son nez dans les histoires de la presse
et donc peut-être qu'il avait glissé à
l'oreille de Jérôme bégulé le patron de
la rédaction du JDD cette interview et
puis cette une pourquoi pourquoi
plusieurs pistes pour dire qu'il existe
encore on peut dire qu'il pèse encore
parce que beaucoup de militants l'ont
abandonné après que lui-même est
abandonné Valérie Pécresse
signifie des manuels Macron et puis il y
a aussi toutes ces affaires judiciaires
qui entourent encore Nicolas Sarkozy
notamment celle dite des écoutes dont le
procès en appel doit se tenir du 28
novembre au 14 décembre donc c'est
plusieurs pistes si vous voulez de de
l'idée de cette interview et Libération
les a résumés dans une qui est à mon
avis est assez bonne regardez là si vous
ne l'avez pas vu encore aujourd'hui
c'est l'emmerdeur voilà avec d'un côté
Nicolas Sarkozy et de l'autre les trois
candidats à la présidente du parti
républicain l'emmerdeur titre d'un film
célèbre des années 70
évidemment ils ont les uns et les autres
réagi oui bah oui évidemment impossible
de laisser passer ça à quelques semaines
d'un congrès où on doit nommer le futur
chef des républicains on va d'abord
écouter Bruno retaillod qui était ce
matin sur France Info il réagit très
fermement aux accusations de Nicolas
Sarkozy sur le conservatisme des
républicains supposés sur les questions
sociales comme l'avortement ou le
mariage pour tous écoutez Nicolas
Sarkozy avait parlé il y a quelques
années d'abrogation de la loi
donné une missive je crois à son
conseiller d'époque monsieur Bisson pour
aller porter à Benoît XVI en 2012 alors
que il devait se représenter pour
indiquer que lui président jamais ce
texte ne passerait donc vous voyez faut
prendre un petit peu de hauteur voilà ça
s'appelle repasser l'église au milieu du
village et en privé Bruno retaillod ne
se prive pas de dire à tous ceux qui
passent que la porte est grande ouverte
si Nicolas Sarkozy veut quitter le parti
et alors côté Éric ciottis alors dans le
fond on est à peu près sur la même ligne
mais dans la forme pas vraiment c'est
beaucoup plus nuancé pourquoi pas parce
que dans cette interview au JDD
justement Nicolas Sarkozy apporte son
soutien à Éric ciotique qui lui-même dit
que Laurent Wauquiez serait le candidat
républicain en 2027 ça va très loin on
est en 2022 et alors le matin sur BFM je
vous propose de d'écouter
Eric Ciotti qui dit non à la proposition
donc Nicolas Sarkozy d'une alliance
entre Emmanuel Macron et les LR
nous avons eu un échange
très récemment mais je n'ai plus vu
Nicolas Sarkozy depuis le mois de mois
d'avril j'ai lu son interview c'est une
interview qui avait de la hauteur celle
d'un ancien chef de l'État qui a fait de
bonnes choses pour la France je le dis
avec respect ce que je ne partage pas et
je le dis très clairement c'est l'idée
mais c'était plutôt un message pour
Monsieur Macron en disant vous avez
échoué avec votre politique elle est
impuissante le en même temps on amène à
rien donc il faut conduire une politique
de droite et il faut une alliance
l'Alliance pour la faire il faut être
deux et moi personnellement je le dis
très clairement je la récuse
bon si on va un peu vite et qu'on essaye
de faire une conclusion de tout ça ça
veut dire que si ni erickiothy ni Bruno
retaille aux veut s'allier avec Emmanuel
Macron
qu'on regarde la portion congrue de LR
sur l'échiquier politique on peut
comprendre à peu près le risque que
courte partie c'est d'être happé par
l'extrême droite qui se notabilise et
qui est beaucoup plus forte en dame de
rapport de force et donc justement c'est
pour cette raison que le RN poursuit de
façon très consciencieuse ce processus
de normalisation pourrait effacer et
briser le plafond de verre qui existe
entre RN et LR je reviens sur la
l'interview de Nicolas Sarkozy Anne
Charlène bézina parce que
il soutient eriki c'est très clair en
interview et en même temps il appelle
cette alliance entre la majorité et LR
est-ce que vous cherchez la cohérence
clairement je pense qu'il a à faire la
synthèse entre différentes ses propos
lui-même doit être un petit peu en grand
écart en et précisément rester sur la
sur la sur la théorie de l'Alliance je
pense que c'était quand même ce qu'il y
avait de plus prudent par rapport aux
propos qui ont été les siens en plein
dans le dur c'est à dire que c'est quand
même une des premières fois sous la
Cinquième République on a un ancien
président qui ouvertment ne soutient pas
le candidat de son groupe et qui va même
jusqu'à proposer à sa famille politique
de mourir en fait de se dissoudre dans
une grande alliance donc ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose assez violent sur
lequel il a attiré des inimitiers et sur
lequel je pense qu'il avait tout lieu
évidemment de continuer à proposer mais
vous disiez quelque chose de très
intéressant qui était notamment la
question de l'alliance des droites parce
que c'est vrai que quand on voit ce qui
se passe en Italie on se dit que les
questions de coalition sont aujourd'hui
très bienvenue on a cette assemblée qui
nous a prouvé aussi que les Français ne
donnent plus vraiment de de satisfaite à
des majorités voilà j'ai envie de dire
de grands partis républicains etc donc
il y a évidemment une question à se
poser à l'avenir de de quelle est la
droite de demain on va parler de la
gauche tout à l'heure mais je pense que
la droite est elle-même dans dans une
crise d'identité qui qui méritera d'être
d'être réglé avant 2027 si c'était
Emmanuel Macron ou Éric Zemmour il
voterait pour y rester moi alors rapide
je vois que vous vouliez intervenir
parce qu'on est presque à la fin le
sondage et une question qui est posée
aux électorats mais qui mêle les
électorats de droite et d'extrême droite
et qui montre quand même un taux de
popularité des personnalités extrêmement
élevées pour Marine pour Marine Le Pen
mais pour Bardella mais pour cioti mais
pour ceux qui pardon pour Zemmour
et on parlait tout à l'heure de
perméabilité des électorats quand même
je pense que celui de LR et celui du
Front national on l'a vu d'ailleurs au
moment des élections est quand même
beaucoup plus rapide à construire que
que de l'autre côté du de l'arc
politique
sur Nicolas Sarkozy il est pas il est
pas testé dans les personnalités mais
pour la tester il y a encore pas très
longtemps on le testait encore il y a
pas très longtemps il faisait partie des
personnalités qui restaient appréciées
auprès de l'électorat droite extrême
droite quand on mettait ensemble toute
la droite puisqu'on fait pareil on met
ensemble toute la gauche aussi pour
regarder les personnalités préférées
mais son étoile avait sérieusement pas
libre pour tout ce que vous avez indiqué
précédemment j'aime bien j'avais pas vu
la Une de Libé sur l'emmerdeur parce que
vous auriez ils auraient pu ajouter sur
la photo outre les candidats pour la
présidence de LR Emmanuel Macron son
entourage parce que c'est un petit peu
le baiser de la mort qui le fait à tout
le monde quand même
et effectivement je rejoins ce que vous
disiez je pense qu'on est tous d'accord
c'est l'évidence que des alliances
programmatiques aujourd'hui entre la
gauche quelle qu'elle soit nups ou et
l'extrême droite ça n'a pas de sens il y
a des passerelles de plus en plus sur
les électorats alors que pendant très
longtemps on parlait de théorie du fer à
cheval à Sciences Po ailleurs mais elle
ne se voyait pas en fait électoralement
et de plus en plus elle existe ce
passage de l'un à l'autre mais les
alliances les plus évidentes elles sont
évidemment entre LR et RN et c'est tout
le jeu de Marine Le Pen et c'est et
c'est ce qu'on voit d'ailleurs en Italie
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participer à ce débat et d'avoir
commenté avec nous les résultats de ce
baromètre donc ça
mascaret je cite Jean-Marie Pernaut le
titre de votre livre le syndicalisme
d'après livre publié aux éditions du
retour voilà merci encore d'avoir
participé à ce